BORIS DEBIC: Welcome,
everybody, to one more Talks
at Google event.
It is my extreme pleasure to
welcome today Dr. William J.
Perry.
The occasion is the publication
of his autobiographical book,
"My Journey at the
Nuclear Brink,"
which also covers
in detail a topic
that we will discuss
among other topics today,
which is one of
nuclear disarmament
and the security in
general in today's world.
I'm not going to give a lengthy
introduction of Mr. Perry,
because you all know how to
use the Google search engine.
But I will read
from a forward which
was written by his
colleague, former Secretary
of State George P. Shultz,
and it is in the book.
Throughout his life
and work, William Perry
has distinguished himself as
a man of high intelligence,
absolute integrity, rare vision,
remarkable accomplishment,
and an unwavering
sense of humanity.
Evidence of these
attributes is vividly
apparent in the gripping
stories contained
in these memoir chronicling
Bill's extraordinary efforts.
I would also like
to mention here,
among all the honors that he
was given throughout life,
probably one of the
most prestigious
would be the Presidential Medal
of Freedom, the United States
highest award for a civilian.
And when he was presented
with this award,
President Clinton
said, "Bill Perry
may will be recorded as the most
productive, effective Secretary
of Defense the United
States ever had."
General John Shalikashvili,
chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff, offered
this assessment
of this extraordinary
public servant.
"Yes, he's a man of vast talent.
Yes, he's a man
of enormous energy
and infectious enthusiasm.
Yes, he's a man of great caring
for those who wear our nation's
uniform and for their families.
But he's first and foremost a
man of unshakable character.
He's a man who will
do what is right,
no matter what the price."
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Perry to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
So I was originally
planning to do
the introduction of
your younger years,
because we want to
connect, in this show,
with the younger
audiences and make
them aware of a grave threat
to our overall security.
But this weekend's
events forced us
into perhaps yet
another territory
that you have covered
in your long career.
Can you comment?
Or do you have any
views on this latest
of the events, which was
the launch of a rocket
by North Korea?
WILLIAM PERRY: Yeah.
I spent a lot of
time in the '90s
with the main mission of trying
to keep North Korea from going
nuclear for a lot of reasons.
Well, I failed.
And the consequence
of that failure
are yet to be played
out, but we see
some of the consequences,
intermediate consequences.
And they've already had a number
of nuclear tests, at least
three of which were successful.
And they have been building
missiles for a long time now.
The missiles up to this point
are medium range missiles.
They threaten South Korea.
They threaten Japan.
They do not threaten
the United States.
With their satellite
launch, which
is no problem in and of
itself, but of course,
to get the satellite into orbit,
you have to use a launcher.
And the launcher is
essentially an ICBM.
So while testing the
satellite, they're
also testing the early
stages of an ICBM.
If they perfect that, which
they have said they plan to do,
then they will have a missile
that can strike the United
States as well.
Even so, this is nothing
if the warhead on it
is high explosive.
The real danger of a
missile is not the missile.
It's the fact that it could
carry a nuclear warhead.
So their nuclear tests are
really of more concern to us
than the missile tests.
The best judgment
of the people I
know who are really expert in
the field of nuclear explosions
and development
of nuclear weapons
believe that the North
Koreans at this point,
while they have a
successful nuclear bomb,
do not have one that
could be compact enough
to be put into a warhead,
that it might take one or two
more nuclear tests before
they would be able to verify
that kind of a design.
So we're perhaps
one or two tests,
nuclear tests, away,
and maybe another one
or two satellite
or ICBM launches
away from them having a
nuclear ICBM which could
threaten the United States.
So it begins to be a
serious issue for us.
BORIS DEBIC: Dr. Perry, I
wanted to go back on the track
that I originally had in mind
for our discussion today.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your younger age,
when you were like
perhaps the younger
members of our audience.
And specifically,
I've heard that you've
been in Hiroshima after
the first explosions there.
What were your impressions
at that young age?
WILLIAM PERRY: Well,
I was actually younger
then than most of you.
I was 14, when a
young man, a friend
came rushing into the room
and said, we are at war.
The Japanese have just
bombed Pearl Harbor.
This is one of these epiphany
events, where you remember
a few decades later
just where you were,
what you were
thinking, and so on.
What I was thinking at the time,
remember, I was 14 years old,
was that I was afraid the
war was going to be over
before I could realize
my dream, which
was to be an Army
Air Corps pilot
and participate in the war.
That's what a 14-year-old
was thinking of that news.
As it turned out, I was right.
The peace treaty was signed
in September of 1945,
when I turned 18
in October 1945.
So I just missed it.
I did then sign up for
the Army Engineers,
and was assigned to the
army of occupation in Japan.
I spent two months in Tokyo, and
then almost a year in Okinawa.
What I saw in Tokyo, in Okinawa
changed my view altogether
about the glamor and
the glory of war.
Tokyo, when I was
there, was in ruins.
There was more damage
and more people
killed than in
Hiroshima, actually,
as a result of thousands
and thousands of fire bombs
dropped over a
period of two years.
And nothing I had read or
heard prepared before me
for just the shock of walking
through the streets of Tokyo
and seeing what was left
of this once great city.
When I got to Okinawa just
two months later, Okinawa,
you may not know
the history of it,
but it was the site of the last
great battle of World War II.
To give you some
metric on it, there
were 100,000 Japanese
soldiers defending Okinawa.
When the battle was
over a few months later,
there were fewer than 10,000.
90% of them, 90,000
Japanese soldiers
died, not just were wounded,
they died in that battle, 90%.
Either they were
killed in battle,
or they committed suicide.
Another 100,000 civilians,
and about 15,000 or 20,000
Americans.
Most of the American
deaths, by the way,
were the result of
kamikaze attacks,
suicide attacks on our ships.
When I landed, when
our ship landed
at Naha, which is the
capital of Okinawa,
there was not a
building left standing.
It was a city about
the size of San Jose.
Nothing was left standing.
The people who survived
were living in rubble.
So that was my first exposure
to what war is really like,
not what you read about what
you hear about in speeches.
I saw all those
scenes of destruction,
and then I reflected
on Hiroshima.
This is what can be done
with 1,000 pound bombs.
In the case of Tokyo,
thousands of them,
over a two year period, and
with thousands of bombers
delivering them-- the
same result in Hiroshima,
in an instant, one airplane
and one bomb, just one bomb.
And even at the
tender age of 18,
I understood this
changed everything.
Einstein had already
said that the advent
of the nuclear bomb,
everything has changed,
except the way we think.
But what I saw in Japan,
Tokyo and Okinawa, even at 18,
my thinking did begin to change.
I began to understand
the vast significance
of the role of nuclear weapons,
how they change everything,
certainly about the way warfare
will ever be waged used again,
and certainly
putting an imperative
that they must never,
ever be used again.
BORIS DEBIC: I think this is
probably the perfect place
to roll the video to compare
what today's young people think
and know about the weapons.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So what do I know
about nuclear weapons?
-I know that nuclear
weapons were invented
in the mid-20th century.
-There was a big scare
that was the Cold War,
but nothing bad
happened, luckily.
-After what happened, after
we bombed the Japanese,
that's the reason
we haven't really
had a World War, because
everybody's scared.
I nobody wants to get nuked.
-Literally, all I know
is I don't want one
to explode near me.
-I hear everything pretty
much dissolves, that is,
within a certain mile radius.
-You wouldn't almost
here anything.
You would just see the
light, and it's out.
-Well, I'd be
dead, but let's say
I were far enough so
that I wouldn't be dead.
I'd probably have
some sort of cancer.
Yay.
-Well, I guess most of the more
detailed knowledge I have came
from a single book that I read.
-Probably from movies and--
-Jokes, TV.
-I mean, video games,
"Fallout," playing those a lot.
-In history class, we see
in the history textbooks
these big mushroom clouds.
Whoa, that's terrifying.
I don't want that.
-I'm interested in physics.
Through that, I
pursued a little more
of the scientific
history of the discovery.
Just a bit, though.
-I would like to think--
or I would hope, one.
-I have no idea.
I don't know.
I would assume in
the couple hundreds,
but I wouldn't go as
far as to say thousands.
-Either a range
between 2,000 and 4,000
or 200,000 and its whereabouts.
-300.
-I would guess that the
United States possesses
10 million nuclear weapons.
-I want to say, like
hundreds of thousands.
But yeah I think
I'm short on that.
We might have more.
-I actually looked that up.
I think it's over 7,000.
-Whoo.
That makes me feel better.
-That's insane that the
US would have 7,000 nukes.
Where are they?
I would like to know.
-I think that there can't
be a winner, because--
-No one is a winner
if mass areas
of the Earth become
uninhabitable, or thousands,
millions of people die.
-I would probably not
feel very victorious
if I demolished a
group of people.
-We've used nuclear weapons
and relatively little happened
to us, so that's a
little frightening.
But that's pretty frightening.
-Oh, like ISIS or Al-Qaeda,
or something like that?
-Definitely possible.
I didn't expect 9/11 to
happen in my lifetime either.
-I don't really remember 9/11.
I was like five.
So for people who
have experience,
breaches of national
security, that's
obviously a bigger concern.
-I say day to day I don't
really worry about terrorists
sitting on nuclear bombs.
-I mean, if somebody got
their hands on one of ours
and used it against
us, that's the worst.
They didn't have to
take it anywhere.
Is already here.
-Odds are not going to happen.
But also, if it
does happen, there's
no use in worrying about
it, because there's nothing
I personally can do to stop it.
So I may as well
just live my life.
-Well, it's certainly
possible to have
a nuclear weapon-free world.
-If the US does it,
it might happen.
But all these other
countries, they see OK,
you're telling us to
get rid of our nukes,
but you're not getting rid of
your nukes, so why should we?
-If there are no more nuclear
weapons or ingredients
to make it, then we're
going to find something
else just as destructive.
-I don't think
it's very realistic
that all countries abandon
their nuclear weapons,
mostly because I have
almost no faith in the US
complying with
something like that.
-There's no way for it to
happen if we don't dare
to imagine that it's possible.
And so my answer to
that question is a yes.
And given that I don't
really know that much
about the state of nuclear
weapons today right now,
I don't know exactly how that
would logistically happen.
But as a lay person
who knows nothing,
I would say yes, hopefully.
Yeah.
[END PLAYBACK]
BORIS DEBIC: Fast
forward, you've
had a great
entrepreneurial career,
and then you ended up
working for the government.
And then comes
your first crisis,
the Cuban Missile Crisis.
Can you tell us a little
bit about why that moment is
important for our history?
WILLIAM PERRY: During
the Cuban Missile Crisis,
I was actually working here
in Silicon Valley at a defense
electronics company.
And I was called
up, but I was also
doing some pro bono
consulting for the government
in the field of technical
missiles, technical factors
about missiles.
And I was called up
one day and asked
to come back to Washington
for an urgent consulting job.
And I said sure, I'll rearrange
my schedule and fly back,
see you next Monday.
He said, no, you
don't understand.
I need to see you right away.
So I got on the red eye,
and flew back to Washington.
The next morning, he
took me into his office,
and to my amazement, showed
me pictures of Soviet missiles
being deployed in Cuba.
And that was my
first introduction
to what came to be called
the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And for the next
eight days and nights,
I worked on a small
team of analysts,
looking at all of the
intelligence information coming
in to try to determine the
status of those missiles, how
big were they, how far could
they fly, when were they
going to be operational?
And that report
went every morning
on the desk of
President Kennedy, who
then used that as
one of the factors
to decide what he should
be doing that day.
I guess my bottom line
is that every day,
I went into that analysis
center I believed
would be my last day on Earth.
That's how close we came
to a nuclear catastrophe
at that time.
And I still believe
to this day that we
avoided that nuclear
catastrophe as much by good luck
as by good management.
BORIS DEBIC: We have
learned some lessons
in that particular episode.
And we're talking about
the era of the Cold
War, that big polarization
They deescalated
in the historical moment, and
people thought that, well, we
can control these weapons.
But these are extremely
complex systems.
We have here Google
engineers in the audience,
and we're talking about many,
many components in this system.
There's a lot of engineering.
There's a lot of communication.
There's a lot of computer
control that goes into that.
Can anybody actually
guarantee the safety
of such a complex system?
Even if we had the
will to say, oh, we're
not going to launch
first or whatnot.
I think you had an episode,
which sheds some light on that.
WILLIAM PERRY: The short
answer to your system is no,
we cannot guarantee it.
And I've had several
experience in my own life that
dramatize the point, but
I'll share just one with you.
At this time, I was
in the Pentagon.
I was the Undersecretary
of Defense
for Research and Engineering.
And I got a call.
This is 1978.
And I got a call one night
at 3 o'clock in the morning.
And I picked up the
phone, barely awake,
and the general on the other end
of the line introduced himself,
the watch officer at the North
American Air Defense Command.
And he said my
computers are showing
200 ICBMs on the way
from the Soviet Union
to the United States.
I'll tell you, I
woke up right away.
Talk about a bucket of
cold water in the face.
And one of the first things
I thought, why in the world
is he calling me?
I was not in the
chain of command.
I was in charge of research and
engineering at the Pentagon.
He was calling me because he
had already determined, happily,
that it was a false alarm.
And the question
he was asking me is
what's wrong with our computer?
What the hell's happening here?
Well, the short answer is, I
could not over the telephone
figure out what was
wrong with his computer.
It took us two days, two days,
to find out what had happened.
And what had happened
was the Sergeant
who came in for his new
watch that evening, instead
of putting the operating
tape into the computer
had put a training
tape into the computer.
And so what we got was a
very realistic simulation
of a launch.
It was human error.
No matter how complex
your systems are,
they're always subject
to human error.
A second one, I
didn't get called
in the middle of the
night, but I was of
involved in trying to fix the
problem after it happened,
was the watch officer
was seeing two missiles
on the way, 22 missiles on the
way, 222 missiles on the way.
He figured, really
very wisely, something
was wrong with his equipment,
which he was right about.
And it took us a day
or two to figure out
what was wrong with
it, and how to fix it.
So I was personally familiar
with an example of human error
and an example of
equipment error.
We did not launch,
which is the good news.
The reason we did not launch,
beside the watch officer
suspecting something was
wrong, which in the second case
was easy, but in the first
place really pretty hard,
was nothing bad was going on
in the world at that time.
And I've always asked myself
on that first case, what if?
What if it had occurred
during a crisis?
What if it occurred during
the Cuban Missile Crisis?
What if it had occurred
during the Sinai Crisis,
which had occurred earlier,
where we were at high alert,
expecting some kind of a launch?
In that case, would we have
gone ahead and actually launched
our missiles and accidentally
started a nuclear war?
So our systems then and now
are subject to those kind
of errors.
The technical factor
which exacerbates
that is that one of our
sets of nuclear missiles,
namely our ICBMs, our
intercontinental missiles,
are subject to being
destroyed in their silos
if they're not launched.
So we if the watch officer
reports to the president
that his system is showing
a launch underway, an attack
on the United
States, the president
has about 10 minutes to
decide whether he should order
the launch of our ICBMs
so that the missiles will
be gone by the time the strike
occurs, about 10 minutes.
And obviously, his
decision is going
to be heavily influenced
by what's actually going
on in the world at the time.
So besides all this technical
duplication, and triplication,
and so on, besides all
these procedures we have,
there's always the question
of context, context.
What's happening
in the world, which
will affect the president?
He has about 10
minutes to digest
that context, plus the
technical information to decide
what to do.
That was true then.
It is still true today.
By the way, I have
just finished a paper
which I'm about to publish,
in which I recommend
that as we begin
the revitalization
of our nuclear systems, we
do not rebuild the ICBMs,
precisely because they are
susceptible to that kind
of a false alarm problem.
I am first to say that
the probability that
leading to an accidental launch
is very low, but why should we
accept any probability?
Why not simply
let it go to zero?
If you can eliminate the
need for a quick launch,
then you can basically avoid
the problem of a false alarm
triggering an accidental war.
BORIS DEBIC: Let's take a couple
of questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
It's a real privilege.
So you just
mentioned that we are
considering revitalizing
the next generation
of our nuclear armament.
How prepared do you think our
politicians and our public
are to consider this
rearmament question?
WILLIAM PERRY: The short
answer is not at all.
All you have to do to listen
to the presidential debates
is to understand that
serious questions like this
don't even enter the discussion.
In fact, I'm just as happy they
don't enter the discussion.
It might create more
noise than information.
Probably most of you
are not aware of it.
We are already proceeding
on the rebuilding,
the recapitalization,
as they call it,
of our nuclear
Cold War arsenal--
the ICBMs, the SLBM, the
submarines, the bombers,
the bombs.
We're in the process
of doing that.
The cost will probably
be upwards of $1 trillion
over the next several decades.
And that is
happening, basically,
without any public discussion.
We're just doing it.
Now, any given year,
when the appropriations
are made to carry
out that plan, there
will be discussion and
debate in the Congress.
But so far, the
public is not only
not participating
in that debate,
they're not even aware
of what's going on.
And what they are not aware
of is pretty much true
of their representatives
in Congress as well.
A few exceptions, though,
in Congress, but not many.
AUDIENCE: One of
the things that you
were known for in your
time at the Pentagon
was modernizing the conventional
technology of our military.
But as you said, we're looking
at now the nuclear side
of the equation.
If you were still
at the Pentagon,
and you were in charge
of making recommendations
about whether we should
and if we should,
how should we modernize
our nuclear weapons?
What would you say?
What do you think that we
should do, if anything?
Assuming that for whatever
reason, immediate,
unilateral disarmament isn't--
WILLIAM PERRY: In the
interest of full disclosure,
I should tell you
that I participated
with George Shultz
and Henry Kissinger,
and Sam Nunn in
three or four op-eds
over the period of the
last six or seven years,
recommending we should be moving
toward zero nuclear weapons.
So I'm not a fan
of nuclear weapons.
With the developments in
Russia in the last few years,
and with Russia
already well embarked
on rebuilding their
Cold War arsenal,
I don't feel that that's
politically feasible right now.
And so my main objective now is
trying to minimize the damage,
trying to recommend
that we proceed
in ways in our rebuilding of
the arsenal that are least
costly and least dangerous.
And on that basis, I've
recommended no ICBMs at all.
Let the ICBM force phase out.
No air launch cruise missile.
Let that phase out.
And on the so-called tactical
nuclear bomb, the B61 bomb,
which we're now refreshing,
not to introduce into it
a low yield.
Now why should I be in favor of
a high yield, not a low yield?
It's because the
low yield invites
the commanders to believe
that it's a usable weapon.
I want to keep the threshold
of using nuclear weapons very,
very high so you do not believe
that a nuclear weapon is just
like a big, conventional
weapon, that there's
something entirely different,
and you should never use them.
So I do not like
the idea of making
nuclear bombs more usable,
which lowering the yields does.
So those would be the main
points I would be pressing.
But more importantly, even
as the Secretary of Defense,
you have something to say
about policy and diplomacy.
I'd be urging the president
to reengage seriously
with the Russians,
and see if together we
can agree to stop altogether
this rebuilding of the Cold War
nuclear arsenal.
If we're not successful
in that, though,
then I'm willing to
support a program,
but a much less expensive
and much less dangerous
program than the one
we are now embarked on.
I would support the
submarine missiles,
because they have no
possibility of false alarm,
and I would support
building a new bomber,
because it can be used
for conventional forces
as the present B-2 is used.
And in this case, it provides
a belt and suspenders
approach in case something
happens to our submarine force,
which I think is very unlikely.
But to build the ICBM as
the third part of the triad
is using belt and suspenders
for the belt and suspenders.
I think it's just silly.
BORIS DEBIC: Ideally,
though, I mean,
if we look at the
world today, it
seems that two of
the major risks
are the worsening of the
relations in the Soviet Union,
like the policies that are
happening both around Ukraine
and Syria recently.
And the other is the
potential for a terrorist,
a non-state actor, to get their
hands on nuclear material.
Do you agree that
those are threats?
WILLIAM PERRY: I do.
The first one could lead to
an accidental war, or a war
by miscalculation.
The second, the terrorism could
lead to one bomb going off
in Washington or San Francisco,
or maybe a couple of bombs.
And we tend to minimize
what that means.
In the preface to my
book, there's a scenario.
It's a hypothetical scenario,
but a very believable,
very real scenario, that
is based on real facts.
And in this
scenario, a terrorist
gets one nuclear bomb.
And I describe how
it could happen.
And he sets it off
Pennsylvania Avenue,
halfway between the White
House and the capitol.
The majority of congressmen
are killed in my scenario.
The president and the
vice president are killed.
The Secretary of Defense and the
chairmen Joint Chiefs of Staff
were testifying at the Congress
at the time this happened.
They were killed.
The presidency devolves
to the president pro tem
of the Senate, who is in Mayo
Clinic in Cleveland being
treated for pancreatic cancer.
So we have a
constitutional crisis.
The terrorists deliver a
message to our TV stations,
broadcast all over
the country, saying,
that was the first bomb.
We have five other bombs
planted in five other cities
in the United States.
They're going to go off
once a weeks from now on.
Stop to imagine what happens to
our cities when that happens,
which is people streaming
out of the cities.
All of our industry shut down,
our economy grinds to a halt.
The country goes into quickly
and total-- this is one bomb.
He doesn't even have to
have the other five bombs.
He just says he has them.
So one bomb could
cause that kind
of an absolute and total chaos.
It makes 9/11 look like
a social outing almost.
It's really, really
catastrophic.
But people don't
really think seriously
about the consequences,
besides the 100,000 people that
are killed, there are
social, and economic,
and political
consequences, which
are really quite profound.
And we're just sitting
here blissfully
unaware of what could happen.
An accidental nuclear war,
a war by miscalculation,
is not a high
probability at all,
but this nuclear terrorism
is really quite believable.
It takes the terrorists getting
a hold of 20 or 30 kilograms
of fissile material.
If he has that, the
making of the bomb
is not that difficult.
We make it difficult.
We want to compress
them to be small enough
to fit into the warheads
to operate under highly
stressed conditions.
If all he wants to do with
a bomb is put it in a truck
and drive it down
Pennsylvania Avenue,
it's not that difficult to make.
The barrier today, the reason
that hasn't happened today,
is he doesn't have the 20 or 30
kilograms of fissile material.
The one bit of good
news I have for you
is that of all the
initiatives of President
Obama in this field, most of
which I'm very critical of,
but the one I'm
very supportive of
is something called the Nuclear
Summit, where he convened
three times now in
his terms in office
the 50 heads of
state, all of whom
are focused on
the question, what
can we do to protect our
fissile material better
than we are now protecting it?
And there have been significant
improvements in the last four
or five years.
The next such meeting, by the
way, comes up in two months,
and it's going to
be in Washington.
And I have high hopes that
will really drive home
this protection message quite a
bit to the ultimate conclusion.
AUDIENCE: Secretary
Perry, related to
that, I've been impressed that
over the last half century
plus, the international
community has
done an amazing job of slowing
down nuclear proliferation.
But it also seems
that at some point
that effort is going
to fail, and you're
going to have a large numbers
of states with nuclear weapons.
So is there something
we can do about that?
WILLIAM PERRY:
Several decades ago,
most of the nations
of the world signed
the Nuclear Nonproliferation
Treaty, which is in force
today.
And that is the main reason
that what President Kennedy
predicted back in
the '60s, namely
that we'd have 30
nuclear countries
by the end of the
century, has not happened.
So we owe a lot to the
Nuclear Nonproliferation
Treaty, nicknamed the NPT.
The NPT is endangered
now for several reasons.
One of which is the two
proliferation threats
of the last few years, one
of them being North Korea.
And nobody's found a good way
of stopping North Korea yet.
And the other
being of Iran, Iran
by really an amazing
concerted effort
of the international
community, we've
reached an agreement with
Iran, which is highly
criticized in this country
by about 55% of our Congress
and by Prime Minister Netanyahu.
Also, it was highly
criticized, I must say,
by the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard.
The irony is, of course,
that they're criticizing it
for entirely different reasons.
The Iranian Revolutionary
Guard is critical,
because they fear
it will not allow
Iran to get a nuclear weapon,
which they want to get.
Of course, Netanyahu and 55%
of the members of Congress
who opposed to it are
opposed because they
fear it will not stop them from
getting nuclear weapons, which
they would like to stop.
Of course, they both
cannot be right,
but that is where we stand
right now on that issue.
The presidential
debates have gotten
into the state of
the purely ridiculous
in discussing this with several
of the Republican candidates,
simply saying flatly
the first day in office,
they're going to terminate the
nuclear deal with Iran, which
my Republican friend
George Shultz says
is just the most ridiculous
statement you could possibly
make.
What it does is it gives
Iran all the benefits
without holding them to
any responsibilities.
Because it is a fantasy to
believe that we could now go
back and renegotiate.
The reason Iran negotiated
in the first place
was that for once in history,
the international community
came together in a very
effective series of sanctions.
The sanctions hurt
Iran enough that they
were willing to sit down and
negotiate a reasonable deal.
The minute the United States
walks out of the deal,
those sanctions go away.
The Europeans would never,
ever support a reimposition
of the sanctions.
And unilateral
sanctions by the US
would not have that
much of an effect.
So that this is demonstrably
a foolish thing to do.
But it's a continual battle
in the area of trying
to stop proliferation.
If Iran were, in fact,
to get a nuclear weapon,
there is no doubt that at least
four or five other countries
in their neighborhood would
follow suit right away.
Let me say one other thing about
the Nuclear Nonproliferation
Treaty.
It has two aspects to it.
One of them is the
non-nuclear powers
agreeing not to build nuclear
weapons, for which they
get certain benefits,
like nuclear technology
for their reactors.
The other half of it
is the nuclear powers,
of which the United
States, of course,
is one, agreeing to work
towards the decrease
of the nuclear
weapons, ultimately
leading to the elimination
of nuclear weapons.
Demonstrably, the
second part of that
is not being followed today.
So the United States
and Russia in particular
are clearly in violation as we
sit here today of the Nuclear
Nonproliferation Treaty,
and that fact does not
go unobserved.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So what's your view on
China's nuclear policy,
especially on their creative use
of some of the ICBM technology?
So they have some
anti-missile, anti-ship ICBMs.
They also have something,
well, that's all.
So what's your view on their
policy, and their technologies?
WILLIAM PERRY: China has had
an ICBM for a good many years.
In fact, my first visit to
China, which was 36 years ago,
I was, at the time, the
Under-secretary of Defense.
They took me out to
the missile test range.
They showed me their
ICBM on its launch pad.
So they at least had an
ICBM for at least 36 years.
I, with my own
eyeballs, have seen it.
For many decades since
then, their policy
was to maintain a
minimal deterrence.
That has a special meaning.
It means just enough
ICBMs to discourage people
from attacking you, but not
enough to cause trouble,
not enough to initiate
trouble on your own.
That's technically called
a minimal deterrence,
and China not only had
that kind of force,
but they have proclaimed that's
the kind of a force they have.
And so none of us who
have been in this field
have been much concerned about
the Chinese nuclear force
being a threat to anybody else.
A minimal deterrence
by definition
means you're not going
to use the force.
It's only there to protect
yourself from being attacked.
In the last five or
six or seven years,
they have been rebuilding
their nuclear forces,
and their ICBM forces, and
their submarine missile forces.
They're obviously moving
beyond the minimal deterrence
force, which I would
think is not good news.
But we do not know yet how
far beyond they are actually
moving.
So that issue remains
unresolved at this point.
I'm hopeful that they're
still staying more or less
within the minimum
deterrence policy,
even though they are
modernizing, and improving,
and strengthening their forces.
As it stands now,
they represent,
I think, no threat to
any other country that's
not trying to threaten them.
AUDIENCE: Some people
have said that the border
between Pakistan and India
is the most dangerous border
in the world, because both
nations have nuclear weapons.
They acquired technology
relatively recently,
and frankly, both
nations hate each other.
So what steps could
be taken, I suppose,
to mitigate the risk of
nuclear war in that region.
WILLIAM PERRY: I would
say that today, Pakistan
represents the greatest
danger in the world
to a nuclear catastrophe
actually happening.
I haven't talked about it.
I've talked about
nuclear terrorism.
I've talked about a possible
accidental war between Russia
and the United States.
But I think more likely
than either of those
would be a regional nuclear
war between India and Pakistan.
And the scenario, it evolved
from just the situation
you described, the
dispute over Kashmir.
The dispute has gone on now
for decades, no closer today
to a resolution than it was
when it started decades ago.
And there have been
three or perhaps
four conventional wars
between India and Pakistan
during that time,
all of which Pakistan
has lost, because they
have smaller country
and have smaller
military forces.
They have responded to this
inferiority in size and power
with irregular warfare, in
particular with terrorism.
And the Pakistani
government has more or less
supported terror groups to
do their bidding in Kashmir.
But sometimes, these terror
groups get off the reservation,
and that happened a few
years ago at a place
called Mumbai, what we
used to call Bombay.
And there was a very serious
terror attack on Mumbai
by a group, a
Pakistan terror group,
which the Indian government
was able to identify,
had some connections with
the Pakistani government.
India very wisely
showed restraint,
and did not invade Pakistan
when that happened.
The question now is
what happens if there
is another such attack,
a Mumbai 2, so to speak.
Shultz and I have
had several meetings
at Stanford with
India and Pakistan,
very senior people from
discussing this very issue.
And it seemed very
clear to both sides
that if that happened
again, that first
of all, the Pakistani side
said they couldn't be sure
their government could prevent
it from happening again.
They didn't have
that much control
over these terror groups.
And the Indian government
said if it happened again,
the Indian government
would feel obliged to have
some sort of a punishment,
which would probably
be a punitive military
incursion into Pakistan
by the Indian army.
And which case,
the Pakistani side
would say if that
happened, the Pakistanis,
rather than losing to the
superior military force,
would use something which they
call tactical nuclear weapons.
Now, I have to tell you,
a tactical nuclear weapon
is a misnomer.
What it means is
a nuclear weapon
that can be used by tactical
forces to fight a war,
not for deterrence.
But it goes off with a bang,
like the Hiroshima bomb.
So don't be misled
by the word tactical.
These are big bombs.
So the Pakistanis
thought their government,
rather than see
itself humiliated
by having its army
defeated, would
use a tactical nuclear
bomb within Pakistan
against the Indian army forces.
They're hoping that the
Indian government would not
respond with nuclear weapons.
The Indians all believe
that if that happened,
the Indian government
would respond.
So that that's the
definition of how
a nuclear war, a regional
nuclear war, could get started.
That scenario is
all too plausible.
So for that reason, I would
agree with the assertion
that the border between
India and Pakistan
is perhaps the most dangerous
place in the world today.
The second most
dangerous place would
be the border between South
Korea and North Korea.
BORIS DEBIC: Dr. Perry, I want
to step a little bit from away
from all the complexities
that you have described today.
I mean, this is very
useful information,
and I am sure that you work with
a lot of current politicians
in trying to think about
political solutions.
But I also would like to
introduce the work that you
started doing with
the organization
that you and your daughter
have founded that is trying
to reach the younger audience.
And perhaps you have something
to offer to the normal man who
is not sitting in Washington DC,
who is going to his every day
job and whatnot.
How can they get involved?
How can I make a difference?
How can my colleague
make a difference
in trying to diffuse this
very volatile situation?
WILLIAM PERRY: You
may have inferred
from what I've already
said that I do not
have great confidence in the
political forces in Washington
today or in Moscow today
recognizing and resolving
the very serious
issues that we face.
And I think a large
reason for that
is because our populace as a
whole does not understand it.
That's why we
conducted this survey.
It's just a random
survey of young people.
What do you know
about nuclear weapons?
And the answer is abysmal,
abysmal ignorance.
And along with the
ignorance, not much concern.
So if we're really going to get
sensible policies for dealing
with the dangers which
we're waving our arms about,
you can wave your arms
about all you want,
but you have got
to have policies
to correct the problems.
We have to find a way
of educating people,
particularly educating
young people, on this issue.
The kids you saw
in that video not
only didn't know
about the Cold War,
they didn't even
know about 9/11.
So this is a grossly
uninformed population.
And so we we're setting
out an educational program
to try to deal
with that problem,
and an education program
directed primarily
at young adults.
We believe that the
reason our policies are
so inadequate today-- let me
back up and say more directly.
A complete declarative
statement is
that the danger of a
nuclear catastrophe today
of one of the kinds
we talked about,
the danger of a
catastrophe today
is greater than it was
during the Cold War.
It is greater than it
was during the Cold War.
We've documented that
several various ways.
I talk about it in
great detail in my book.
And I'm just writing another
paper now, dealing specifically
with it, why I believe
that to be true,
and how I can document it, why
I believe it is an accurate
way of assessing it.
If it's greater today,
it's also perfectly clear
that our policies are
not adequate for dealing
with those dangers.
We're blissfully going
ahead, both we and Russia,
rebuilding the Cold
War nuclear arsenal.
Never mind the $1 trillion
cost associated with it,
the dangers associated with
that are very, very real.
So we need a program
of education.
You can't rant about policies
if you don't understand
the underlying issues.
So the first step
is education, and it
has to be some kind
of a mass education.
So sure, I teach a course
at Stanford on this subject.
I get a couple hundred
students, which is nice,
but that doesn't influence
what's going on in the world.
I had to find a way of
getting the information
through to hundreds of
thousands of students,
or even millions
of young people.
And so, obviously, the internet
is the only way to do that.
And we're trying in our
project to put together
media that can work, that can
be effective over the internet,
and which will attract young
people to read it and get
engaged with it.
One of the reasons I'm happy
to talk with this group today
is we need help with
what we're doing,
and certainly no one ought
to be better qualified
on how to effectively
use the internet
to communicate with millions
of people than people here
at Google.
So we're in our own fumbling
way doing these things now.
We're preparing videos,
of which you saw one.
You did not see the
video we prepared
on nuclear terrorism,
which actually lays out
the scenario I described to you
about an attack on Washington.
BORIS DEBIC: That
video is available
online on your [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM PERRY: Yeah, absolutely.
It is certainly
available online.
But it's a powerful
video, which drives home
how real this problem is,
and how serious it is.
So we would like very much to
get people interested in this
by educating them.
And what can they do
once they get educated?
The first thing is to
help educate others, focus
on specific policy issues.
For example, the
issue of should we
be rebuilding our ICBM force?
That's a very concrete,
specific issue.
And you can build up
quite a head of steam
in trying to slow
that process down,
if you get enough people
concerned about it,
and talking about
it, and debating it.
But it takes masses of people.
It can't be done with
a classroom of people.
And again, that means you
have to communicate over
the internet.
One of the things I was hearing
is that knowledge, of course,
is necessary, before
you speak intelligently
about these problems, but
you also must have conviction
that this is a serious problem.
Not only your future
depends on it,
but your children's
future depends upon it,
if you want to do
something about it.
I want to end on my
comment here by giving you
a quote from the Irish poet
WB-- William Butler Yates,
who said something very
meaningful on this problem.
I'll just quote it
for you exactly.
He said, "the best lack
conviction, while the worst are
full of passionate intensity."
And that's what I see when I
look out in the world today.
I see people ranting and raving
passionately about how vital
it is to be rebuilding all
of our ICBMs and so on,
and the rest, well, you saw
it in the picture up there.
What can I do?
That's not a sufficient answer.
If you have the conviction,
you educate yourself.
You help educate other people.
You associate yourself with
a group, like our group,
for example, that is actually
working on the problem,
and help them do it.
There are things you can
do, if you, first of all,
get the conviction that you
should be doing something,
and then take the time
to educate yourself
on what the real issues are.
BORIS DEBIC: Please join
me in thanking Dr. Perry
for visiting us here at Google.
WILLIAM PERRY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]